foreign
thank you
okay
so much
[Music]
foreign
consort The Prince and Princess of Wales
and other members of the Royal Family
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
Your Grace my Lord Chancellor prime
minister Mr Speaker
Lord speaker Your Excellence is my lords
aldermen sheriffs Chief commoner
ladies and gentlemen
good evening
and on behalf of my co-hosts the two
sheriffs tonight Alastair King
and Andrew Marsden
may I wish you all a very warm welcome
to Guild Hall for this Lord mayor's
banquet
prime minister Your Grace Lord
Chancellor Chancellor of the exchequer
thank you so much for being here with us
this evening
I am immensely proud to stand here
as the 694th Lord mayor of the city of
London
proud that is of the city of London
where I have worked for over 40 years
but deeply humbled as your lord man
but first let me pay tribute to the
693rd Lord mayor Vincent Kevin
the first Irish citizen to be Lord mayor
and I'm delighted to be continuing the
trend
it's a bit like Dublin buses you wait a
hundred years for an Irish Lord mayor
then two come along one after the other
yours was a truly historic mayorality
Vincent with the celebration our first
and probably our last Platinum Jubilee
and then of course the death of her
majesty the queen
and the accession of his majesty the
king
through all this you were a great
representative of the city
all these events
reminded us not only of Her Majesty's
close bonds with the city
but of the importance of our
constitutional monarchy
for our stability
and our continuity
as a nation
my late Lord mayor
you devoted your marital to people and
purpose making sure the city provides
opportunities to all people across the
UK
and ensuring that the city uses its
Financial Firepower
for positive social purpose
which you did with your Finance for
impact Summit
at the local level
both you and Amanda highlighted the
scourges of homelessness and hunger in
our capital
in this way you demonstrated the
unspoken work of the city that societal
aspect that does not fit neatly with the
hackneyed stereotype of a selfish City
it is something that Felicity and I will
also vigorously pursue
promoting not only a resilient and
resourceful City
but a responsible City too
building on the theme of my Lord mayor's
show two weeks ago children charity and
Community which involved a record number
of young people from diverse backgrounds
in many cases experiencing the city of
London for the first time
as the cost of living crisis Looms
we now have to show how our financial
purpose
can meet society's needs
as William Wright from new Financial
puts it
the banking finance and capital markets
industry touches virtually every aspect
of millions of people's daily lives it
directs Capital into the real economy to
help companies raise money to invest in
jobs innovation
infrastructure growth and prosperity in
every corner of the United Kingdom
the industry helps millions of
individuals across the country to save
and invest for the future and for their
retirement
by investing in these and other assets
they are creating a virtuous circle of
investment and growth
and the insurance industry protects
millions of people's lives homes Health
cars and so much else
underwriting risks and enabling trade
and the transportation of goods
but now
our financial services industry
must find ways to help people bridge
this crisis
by providing Affordable Credit
debt repayment deferrals premium waivers
on insurance policies and so much more
I will convene a financial inclusion
Summit
urgently to identify best practice with
the FCA and develop a coordinated plan
to see how the city can play its part
in tackling this looming societal
challenge
[Music]
[Applause]
at the same time however we have to
tackle the other great challenge
how are we set about financing our
future
as a Prelude to us being able to tackle
that stability is required
and I applaud the way that the
chancellor and the bank of England moved
swiftly to calm guilt markets after the
crisis of confidence
triggered by the mini budget in
September
nevertheless
the kindness of strangers that Mark
Carney described
has its limits
at the CBI last week prime minister you
spoke about wanting to be bold decisive
and radical
and emphasized Innovation and growth as
well as green and sustainable Finance
kirstama spoke about his growth plans
too and called for governments business
and trade unions to work together for
growth that puts the interests of
working people first
this Confluence of thinking is Timely
and we must indeed work together to
formulate medium-term plans so that we
can deliver
consistently and without deviation an
economy that benefits the whole nation
and Regulators must be part of that
thinking too
because regulation has been a barrier to
growth especially in the area of
unleashing capital in our pensions life
insurance and personal savings sectors
if we are too risk averse then we put
ourselves at a competitive disadvantage
that has to change it has to change now
while the financial services and markets
bill is being debated because that must
enshrine the way forward
I know that this is well understood by
Sam Woods at the pra and Nico rati at
the FCA even if they have to look at it
through a different lens I'm delighted
they're both here tonight and I thank
them for all that they do for a strong
independent regulatory system is a key
foundation stone of a leading Global
Financial Center
foreign
Minister I was in Northern Ireland with
our policy chairman Chris Hayward last
week talking to exciting Tech and Green
Tech businesses
and the British and the British Irish
Chamber of Commerce
and I will be in Cardiff later this week
our islands are bursting with Enterprise
and creativity
but growth economy companies have become
reliant on investment from sophisticated
overseas investors mostly North American
that look hungrily at the UK's startups
and scale-ups
and that's because we have so much going
for us
we have seven of the top 20 universities
in the world the biggest number on
fintech companies and unicorns in Europe
by far
phenomenal Talent both Homespun
and entrepreneurs attracted by our
unique offering from all over the world
so we need to send them a clear message
that we are serious about supporting
them
by accelerating the regulatory reform
set out in the hill Khalifa and Austin
reviews by removing the structural
obstacles to growth in our high
potential sectors like fintech and life
sciences
and most importantly by providing the
accelerator capital for these companies
and their talented entrepreneurs
at each stage of their Journey
so they can start scale and stay here in
the UK
now the reforms announced to the
solvency II regime are a very welcome
step in the right direction
and we'll make the funding of long-dated
infrastructure loans by insurance
companies easier
and these plans must be successfully
implemented
I believe we need a private sector UK
growth fund of at least 50 billion
pounds
to invest in long-term asset classes in
infrastructure in property and in
private Equity supporting the growth
economy Green Technology and Renewables
we have the second largest pension
savings pot in the world after the
United States
but only seven percent of pension assets
are invested in these real economy asset
classes that is in contrast to an
average of 19 for the economies with the
other largest pension pots globally
if that moved from just seven percent up
to ten percent it would unleash 40
billion pounds
that would be a good start
prime minister [ __ ] 27 has reminded us
all how urgent investment in renewable
energy is
for all of us
otherwise
there won't be a future to finance
and that is why the city of London has
committed to hosting the Net Zero
delivery Summit next May
with the cop Egyptian presidency
with a clear aim of measuring delivery
against the promises made with G fans at
cop 26
and looking ahead to cop28
with a private sector UK growth fund
into which everyone's defined
contribution pension invests a small
percentage of their savings
that is capable of allocating capital
to renewable energy opportunities
we can secure people's long-term
environment environmental and Financial
Health
giving everyone a stake in our future
wealth and success
financing our future by helping people
Finance their own futures
prime minister the city stands ready to
play its part
this ecosystem of Financial and
Professional Services companies that
coexist symbiotically in such a close
geographic area
a robust regulatory regime
underpinned by our world-leading legal
services our independent Judiciary and
the Primacy of the rule of law is not
mirrored anywhere else in the world
that is what makes the city of London
such an extraordinary place to do
business
and ladies and gentlemen that is why
we now have a huge opportunity
and indeed a responsibility
to be the engine driving the economy
forward
by financing our future
I look forward to working with you all
over the year ahead
for a resilient resourceful and
responsible City
supporting the whole United Kingdom
so now can I ask please government
ministers to remain seated and everyone
else to please rise if you're able and
join me in the toast
his Majesty's ministers
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
race silence for the prime minister
foreign
ladies and gentlemen
whether by virtue of history or accident
of geography our country has always
looked out to the world
I was born in Southampton
a port city the victorians called the
gateway to the world where the Mayflower
set sail where Spitfires were built and
Allied troops embarked on D-Day
and just as we look out to the world so
the world often looks to Britain
like many others my grandparents came to
the UK
via East Africa in the Indian
subcontinent and made their lives here
in recent years we've welcomed thousands
of people
from Hong Kong
Afghanistan and Ukraine
we're a country that stands up for our
values
that defends democracy by actions not
just words
a country that commits not just our
resources but our Ingenuity to better
the lives of others and ourselves
Ukrainian flags have flown
over almost every town and City on these
islands for the past nine months
no one told people to put them there
they felt moved to show solidarity with
people they've never met
in a country most have never even
visited
to show their faith In fairness
freedom
and the rule of law
these values are constant
they are set in stone
but as the world evolves
so does our application of those values
as Edmund Burke argued circumstances and
context are everything
and today
the pace of geopolitical change is
intensifying
our adversaries and competitors plan for
the long term
after years of pushing at the boundaries
Russia is challenging the fundamental
principles of the UN Charter
China is conspicuously competing for
Global influence using all the levers of
state power
now in the face of these challenges
short-termism or wishful thinking will
not suffice
we can't depend on Cold War arguments or
approaches or mere sentimentality about
our past
so we will make an evolutionary leap in
our approach
this means being stronger in defending
our values and the openness on which our
prosperity depends
it means delivering a stronger economy
at home
as the foundation of our strength abroad
and it means standing up to our
competitors not with grand rhetoric but
with robust pragmatism
now we will do all this not only through
our diplomatic expertise Science and
Technology leadership and investment in
defense and security
but by dramatically increasing the
quality and depth of our Partnerships
with like-minded allies around the world
we will set out more detail in the
updated integrated review in the new
year including how we'll work with
friends in the Commonwealth the US the
Gulf States Israel and others
but tonight
I'd like to describe how we're already
making this evolutionary leap in three
other places
first
as we stand by Ukraine we're also
reinvigorating our European
relationships to tackle challenges like
security and illegal migration
second
we're taking a longer term view on China
strengthening our resilience and
protecting our Economic Security
and third
we're seizing the huge opportunities on
offer in the indo-pacific by building
deep and long-lasting Partnerships
first Ukraine
in Kiev I just saw how Russia's Focus
is shifting from bruising encounters on
the battlefield
to brutalizing the civilian population
it was written
in the scarred buildings and the piles
of rubble lining the streets
in the stories of the First Responders I
met
from liberated Harrison
from the torture chambers
to the booby traps left in children's
toys
as the world comes together to watch the
World Cup
I saw
how an explosive device
had been hidden inside a child's
football
seeking to make it a weapon of War
it defies belief
so being no doubt we will stand with
Ukraine for as long as it takes
next year we will maintain or even
increase our military aid and we will
provide new support for air defense to
protect the Ukrainian people and the
critical infrastructure they rely on
by protecting Ukraine we protect
ourselves
with the fall of Kabul the pandemic the
economic strife
some said the West was weak
in fact our response in Ukraine has
shown the depth of our Collective
resolve
Sweden and Finland are joining NATO
Germany is increasing its defense
spending Partners as far afield as
Australia Japan and South Korea are
standing with us
we've developed an entirely new
sanctions model
and through NATO and the joint
expeditionary Force we're guarding
against further Russian aggression
whether in the East or the high North
we're also evolving our wider
post-brexit relations with Europe
including bilaterally and engaging with
the new European political community
but this is not about greater alignment
under my leadership will never align
with EU law instead
will Foster respectful mature
relationships with our European
Neighbors on shared issues like energy
and illegal migration
to strengthen our Collective resilience
against strategic vulnerabilities
and that brings me to my second point
we also need to evolve our approach to
China
now let's be clear the so-called Golden
Era is over
along with a naive idea that trade would
automatically lead to social and
political reform
but nor should we rely on simplistic
Cold War rhetoric
we recognize China poses a systemic
challenge to our values and interests
a challenge that grows more acute as it
moves towards even greater
authoritarianism
instead of listening to their people's
protests the Chinese government has
chosen to crack down further
including by assaulting a BBC journalist
the media and our parliamentarians must
be able to highlight these issues
without sanction including calling out
abuses in xinjiang and the curtailment
of freedom in Hong Kong
now of course
we cannot simply ignore China's
significance in world affairs
to global economic stability or issues
like climate change
the US Canada Australia Japan and many
others understand this too
so together
we'll manage this sharpening competition
including with diplomacy and engagement
and much of this is about dramatically
improving our resilience particularly
our Economic Security
that's why we created new powers under
the National Security and investment Act
it's like we use why we use them this
month to block the sale of Newport wafer
Fab it's why we took action on 5G
and it's why we're ending Global
dependence on authoritarian regimes
starting with Russian gas
now we're also acting to deepen our ties
in the indo-pacific the third example of
where we're evolving our approach
before I came into politics like many of
you I invested in businesses around the
world and the opportunity in the
indo-pacific is compelling
take Indonesia which I visited just this
month it's a young vibrant country
the world's third largest democracy
poised to become a top five global
economy
by 2050 the indo-pacific will deliver
over half of global growth
compared with just a quarter from Europe
and North America combined
that's why we're joining the
trans-pacific trade deal the cptpp
delivering a new FDA with India and
pursuing one with Indonesia
but in the indo-pacific economics and
security are indivisible
sixty percent of global trade passes
through Regional shipping routes
including choke points like the Straits
of Malacca it's in our interests to keep
these trade lines open
that's why we joined the five Power
Defense arrangements with Australia
Malaysia New Zealand and Singapore half
a century ago
and it's why we're evolving new
long-term defense industrial and
technological Partnerships like orcas
with Australia and the US and the future
combat air system with Italy and Japan
by deepening these ties
will help protect the arteries and
ventricles of the global economy
supporting security and prosperity
both at home in our European
neighborhood and in the indo-pacific
my Lord mayor
as we meet here tonight
the people of Ukraine are hunkered down
in freezing temperatures
on the front line of the fight for
freedom
in Iran
women are displaying
the most humbling and breathtaking
courage refusing to bow to thuggish
Theocratic control
and tomorrow Iran's football team will
again stand with them in solidarity
facing unknown consequences as a result
freedom and openness
have always been the most powerful
forces for progress
but they have never been achieved by
standing still
as Henry Kissinger wrote
during periods of Crisis where the war
technological change or economic
dislocation management of the status quo
may be the riskiest choice of all
under my leadership
we won't choose the status quo
we will do things differently
we will evolve anchored Always by our
enduring belief in Freedom openness and
the rule of law
and confident that in this moment of
Challenge and competition
our interests
will be protected
and our values
will always prevail
thank you
foreign
thank you